The red planet.
Earth's neighbor.
And the destination of NASA's most ambitious
mission to date.
But this expedition will be harder than we
ever thought possible.
It hurts to think of how hard it is, the
farthest a human being has ever been from the
earth. We've got to take every precaution.
As NASA's astronauts arrive at Mars, they
will face a huge obstacle.
Landing on the planet is a daunting task.
In the past, Mars hasn't always rolled out
the welcome mat.
Mars is kind of like a graveyard for
spacecraft.
It's actually really hard to send something
from Earth and landed on Mars.
This is how the European Space Agency hoped
its $250 Million Schiaparelli Lander would
touch down in 2016.
But the lander systems got it wrong.
The parachute, detached early, sending the
craft into freefall for 33 seconds.
Schiaparelli smashed into the surface at 335
miles per hour, leaving a deep black scar in
the Martian landscape.
It turns out that Mars is actually a
particularly difficult planet to land on.
Even humanity's most brilliant engineers.
We've got about a 50% success rate when it
comes to landing on Mars.
The red planet is littered with dead
spacecraft that didn't nail the landing.
And for NASA's first crewed descent to Mars,
the space agency must learn from these
mistakes. But as the crew hurtles towards
the surface, they're battling the same
problem as all the landers that failed
before.
The Martian atmosphere is 100 times thinner
than Earth's, so it can't provide the drag
needed to slow a spacecraft down.
So it's not like the Earth where you can have
these big giant parachutes that gently glide
you down to the surface.
You can use some of the air, but it's hard.
The Red Planet's thin atmosphere is a problem
that has been billions of years in the
making.
Mars doesn't have a large atmosphere because
it's constantly being peeled away due to the
lack of protection of a magnetic field.
The solar wind can strip away an atmosphere
on earth.
A liquid metal core creates a magnetic field
which shields the planet and helps maintain
the atmosphere.
But Mars is different.
4.5 billion years ago, Mars and Earth formed
from dust and gas in space.
Mars formed where building materials were
scarce.
Its growth was stunted.
So Mars is much smaller than the Earth.
It's a factor of ten smaller than the Earth.
And that factor of ten in mass is important.
All of that extra mass allows the inside of
the earth to stay warm and to have a core
that's rotating, which generates a magnetic
field.
4 billion years ago, the churning heart of
Mars started to cool and solidify.
And with no hot core, there's no magnetic
field being generated.
All of the high velocity charged particles
coming from the sun pick away at the
atmosphere and slowly tear it away.
We know it's losing atmosphere every second
due to the solar wind.
So, you know, bye bye atmosphere.
If NASA's astronauts arrive on Mars as
planned in 2035, the settlers will find one
of the Red Planet's biggest challenges.
Is it dust?
That's sticky.
Basically, light from the sun can give this
stuff a static charge and then it clings to
stuff. So it's not just a matter of like
standing on a doormat outside your space
habitat and shaking yourself off.
It's going to get in your spacesuit, it's
going to coat your visor, it's going to cover
your solar panels.
If you get it in your lungs, it's not a good
thing.
We have to figure out how to clear this
stuff out.
300 feet.
-11. Through the sixties and seventies ago,
Apollo astronauts walked on the moon.
When they returned to their landing module,
they brought moon dust back with them.
The lunar dust clogged seals, caused
equipment to overheat, resulted in false
instrument readings, and even made
astronauts sick.
You'd want to be breathing in fine, dusty
material by itself.
You can get things like silicosis.
It's a it's a almost basically a lung cancer
that you can get just from breathing the dust
itself. You don't want to do that.
The red planet is covered in sticky dust.
And new research suggests it all came from
one place.
The Medusa Fossae formation when the 600
mile long volcanic deposit formed 3 billion
years ago, it was around half the size of
the United States.
But the Martian winds have eroded this
structure and spread the dust across the
entire planet.
When the wind whips up this dust, it can
have disastrous consequences.
The real problem is just that all these fine
particles get lofted into the atmosphere and
it takes a really long time for them to
settle back out.
And what the dust does is it just gets up in
the sky and it sits there and sits there and
sits there.
As more material gets lifted into the
atmosphere, it forms huge dust storms.
The storms are so huge, they block out the
sunlight and cool the Martian surface.
Creating a temperature difference between
the ground and atmosphere that causes winds
to increase and the storms to grow.
And NASA's Opportunity Rover knows firsthand
the dangers of being trapped in one.
Opportunity was a NASA rover sent to Mars to
hunt for signs of past water on the surface
and potentially signs of past life.
This is a rover that we really worked with so
long, knew so well, and who had come up with
so many amazing new results from Mars.
June 2018.
Opportunity was 15 years into its mission.
When giant clouds of dust appeared on the
horizon.
Nassar could only watch as the storm grew
and grew.
Once this dust storm coated the entire
planet, it blocked the sun, and the sun was
the source of Opportunity's power.
Opportunity works using solar panels, and so
it gradually got less and less and less
electricity.
For opportunity, there was no escape.
Lost in the darkness.
Opportunities. Power reserves slowly ran
dry.
The rover fell silent.